en este vídeo vamos a hablar sobre el
crecimiento exponencial que es lo que
genera una explosión poblacional la
mayoría de los estudiantes comprenden el
crecimiento exponencial pero a veces las
matemáticas pueden ser algo difíciles
así que vamos a analizar esto paso a
paso comencemos con este conejo de aquí
y digamos que forma parte de una
población no tendremos solamente un
conejo sino cierto número de conejos en
nuestra población y en todas las
ecuaciones nos referiremos a esto como n
que es el tamaño de la población esto va
a cambiar conforme pase el tiempo pero
esta será nuestra población inicial que
llamamos n vamos a organizar a los
conejos para poder contarlos nuestra n
inicial será de 10 conejos en el tiempo
0 ahora nuestra población puede aumentar
disminuir o permanecer igual y lo que va
a determinar esto será nuestra tasa de
crecimiento este es la segunda letra que
deben recordar r que nos va a indicar
que tanto cambia la población con el
tiempo y hay solamente dos cosas que
afectan a la cantidad de población
nuevos conejos que serán los nacimientos
y los conejos que fallecen lo que serán
las muertes así que ambas cosas van a
contribuir al cambio en la población
pero es algo per cápita lo que significa
que tenemos que dividir esto entre n que
es el tamaño original de la población
permítanme agregar unos conejos bebés
unos 5 conejos bebés de manera que
tenemos 5 nacimientos y digamos que se
murieron dos conejos no se preocupen son
solamente conejos virtuales así que
tenemos dos muertes tuvimos 5
nacimientos y 2 muertes y nuestra n es
la población original de 10 por lo que
el valor de nuestra r va a ser 5 menos 2
entre 10 que es 3 entre 10 lo que nos da
punto 3 el valor de nuestra r es punto 3
por lo que nuestra tasa de crecimiento
es punto 3 esto significa el factor con
el que aumenta nuestra población
si tomo 10 y lo multiplicó por punto 3
voy a tener 3 que es lo que ha aumentado
o crecido nuestra población algo que
deben conocer sobre la tasa de crisis
es que si el ecosistema es estable la
tasa de crecimiento no va a cambiar con
el tiempo y ustedes pueden pensar que si
no cambia la tasa de crecimiento
entonces la población va a aumentar
siempre con la misma cantidad pero esto
no es así veamos lo que sucede tomamos
esta tasa de crecimiento de punto 3 para
la siguiente generación y ahora en lugar
de multiplicarla por diez vamos a
multiplicar la por 13 si lo hacemos
vamos a usar esta ecuación de aquí que
es el cambio de n entre el cambio en t
tomando nuestra tasa de crecimiento que
es punto 3 y ahora la multiplicamos por
13 ya no tendremos 3 sino que tendremos
3.9 y si lo redondeamos resulta que
tendremos otros cuatro conejos más lo
que aumenta nuestra población a 17
conejos
aun cuando nuestra erre no cambia como
cada vez la multiplicamos por un número
más grande vamos a tener una mayor
cantidad de conejos para la siguiente
generación ahora hagamos los cálculos
para la tercera generación en donde
ahora multiplicamos puntos
por 17 lo que nos da 5.1 que podemos
redondear a 5 conejos
si ahora multiplicamos nuestra tasa de
crecimiento por 22 nos dará 6.6 que
redondeamos a 7 conejos y lo sumamos lo
que nos da una población de 29 aquí
pueden ver que la población está
aumentando ahora les puedo hacer algunas
preguntas difíciles la primera pregunta
no es tan difícil y es cuál será la
población en el tiempo número 5 para
resolverlo tomamos este 29 y lo
multiplicamos por punto 3 y el resultado
lo sumamos al 29
qué tal si les preguntara cuál sería la
población en el tiempo 10 o en el tiempo
30 esto ya no es tan fácil de calcular y
seguramente van a necesitar algo de
ayuda en mi caso cuando necesito algo de
ayuda lo primero que hago es usar mi
hoja de cálculo vamos a abrir excel y
trataremos de recordar estos números
vamos a reconstruir nuestra tabla del
lado izquierdo tenemos cero como nuestro
primer tiempo y uno será nuestro segundo
tiempo puedo ahorrarme tiempo en excel
seleccionando estas celdas tomando esta
esquina y jalando la hacia donde quiero
que se incremente mi conteo así que
llevemos esto hasta el año 30 ya tenemos
esto cuál era nuestra población original
era de 10 lo escribimos aquí en cuál
será la siguiente población vamos a
escribir una fórmula en este recuadro
escribiendo el signo de igual recuerdan
que hicimos tomamos nuestra población
original le damos clic aquí y a esto le
vamos a sumar la tasa de crecimiento que
era de punto 3 y la vamos a multiplicar
por nuestra población original esto nos
da 3
nuevamente lo que hicimos fue tomar lo
que había en esta celda y le sumamos lo
que había en esta celda multiplicada por
punto 3 y con la magia de la hoja de
cálculo puedo tomar esto y lo vamos a
copiar en todas estas celdas de manera
que haga lo mismo una y otra vez y así
hará todos los cálculos por nosotros
tenemos los valores que teníamos antes
13 17 22 todo nos suena familiar
obviamente esto no está redondeado por
lo que no nos dará la cantidad exacta de
conejos pero ahora podemos ver esta
curva exponencial que tiene forma de j y
ahora si podemos responder a las
preguntas en el tiempo 5 tendremos unos
37 conejos en el tiempo 10
tendremos 138 conejos y si vamos a este
tiempo 30 vamos a tener 26 mil 199
conejos lo que son muchísimos conejos en
poco tiempo así pueden ver el
comportamiento del crecimiento
exponencial lo bonita de las hojas de
cálculo es que puedo jugar con la
información digamos
en lugar de tener una tasa de
crecimiento de punto 3 la vamos a
cambiar a punto 1 copiamos esto de nuevo
hasta abajo y vamos a tener otra curva
en forma de j aunque ésta no estará tan
empinada como la anterior ya que al
final no tendremos tantos conejos pero
aún así vamos a tener un crecimiento
exponencial cambiamos de nuevo este
valor y hagamos los 0 si lo hacemos
obtenemos 10 aplicamos esto de nuevo en
todas las celdas y veremos que no
tenemos aumento alguno quedará todo el
tiempo con el valor de 10 una de las
preguntas difíciles que les hago a mis
estudiantes es qué pasará si tenemos una
tasa de crecimiento negativa por ejemplo
ve - punto 3 aquí nos dará un 7 y si
aplicamos esto en todas las celdas nos
vamos a aproximar a un límite nos vamos
a aproximar a 0 esto es porque al
principio vamos a quitar grandes
cantidades y luego aquí tenemos
cantidades menores conforme la población
se hace cada vez más pequeña esto
podemos hacerlo con hojas de cálculo
pero no siempre tenemos a la mano una
hoja
a veces solo necesitamos una calculadora
y un poco de álgebra veamos la solución
algebraica tenemos esta ecuación para el
crecimiento exponencial el cambio de n
en t va a ser igual a n que es el tamaño
de la población multiplicada por uno más
r donde r es la tasa de crecimiento y
esto lo vamos a elevar a t donde t es el
tiempo vamos a asegurarnos de que esto
funciona veamos t igual a cero
sustituimos nuestros números ponemos 10
en lugar de en nuestra población
original aquí dejamos a 1 y r la
sustituimos con punto 3 y la elevamos a
la potencia 0 que es nuestro tiempo
simplificamos esto y recordamos que
cualquier cosa elevada a la potencia 0
va a ser igual a 1 lo que nos da 10
parece que está funcionando pero no se
confíen sigamos con t igual a 1
sustituimos el tiempo con 1 m sigue
siendo 10 esto es uno más r r no está
cambiando pero ahora elevamos todo esto
a la primera potencia y cualquier cosa
elevada a 1
igual a la misma cosa por lo que nos
queda 1.3 y al multiplicar por 10 nos da
13 hagamos lo mismo para t igual a 2
sólo ponemos 2 aquí pues es lo único que
está cambiando
tenemos 1.3 a la segunda potencia osea
lo elevamos al cuadrado y nos da 1.69
que lo multiplicamos por 10 y nos queda
16.9 que es casi 17 probemos ahora con
el tiempo igual a 30 elevamos esto a la
potencia 30 y nos da 26.199 lo que
coincide con nuestra hoja de cálculo
tendremos muchos conejos muy rápidamente
esta es la solución algebraica es una
forma rápida de calcular el crecimiento
usando la población original el tiempo y
la tasa de crecimiento ahora quiero
preguntarles algo digamos que en lugar
de conejos tenemos bacterias la bacteria
e.coli puede reproducirse en 20 minutos
es decir puede hacer una copia de sí
misma en 20 minutos digamos
ninguna de estas bacterias muere así que
no tenemos tasa de mortalidad por lo que
nos quedan los nacimientos entre en
cuántos nacimientos tendremos si nos
dividimos a la mitad tendremos un collie
nuevo nuestra población original era de
1 por lo que ahora tendremos una r igual
a 1 en lugar de aumentar por punto 3
ahora vamos a aumentar por 1 que es lo
mismo que un aumento del 100 por ciento
al principio tenemos una bacteria y
después tenemos 2 bacterias que es un
aumento del 100 por ciento de bacterias
más que el número original ahora tenemos
dos después tendremos 4 luego 8 luego 16
32 y pueden ver como el crecimiento
exponencial nos da una gran cantidad de
bacterias muy rápidamente otra pregunta
que les hago es el cielo es el límite
después de 20 generaciones vamos a tener
casi no alcanzo a leer algo así como 5
millones así que esto sigue creciendo
por siempre
r no va a ser igual siempre les dije una
mentira conforme aumenta la población se
irán quedando sin alimentos recursos y
espacios por lo que r va a cambiar y
comenzaremos a ver algo llamado
crecimiento logístico lo que tiene un
conjunto de ecuaciones diferentes y lo
veremos en otro vídeo esto fue el
crecimiento exponencial y nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo